Today's video is sponsored by Knights Chronicle. Nice Chronicle is an anime inspired RPG available on the iOS and Android. Yes
It's a mobile game played anywhere play while you're sitting player while you're walking play it when you're on the toilet, dude
What the heck for a mobile game?
I was actually really impressed bhai's combat system which had a surprising amount of depth with satisfying
Animations and that includes over a hundred heroes to choose from voice by actors
You're likely very familiar with from anime
like Yuki Kaji playing Theo again a psycho duckling Leona
Tomokazu sugita playing Marduk and many many more which can find by going through the codex
Characters are constantly being added but it also has multiplayer, too
So you can team up in PvE or fuck each other up in
PvP links in the description below to download it on whatever phone you have. And with that said let's get on with the video
Hey guys and welcome to summer 2018 anime in a nutshell if this is your first time here, we're gonna be watching summer anime
It's gonna be awesome. It's gonna be high every new season we come in with high hopes and positivity
Hey guys welcome to summer 2018 anime in a nutshell, this is your first time here just
Just get out where you can it's not it's not fucking worth it
So brooding guy wakes up on an island and he's from the future
But he can't remember anything and it's a mystery because he has to do
something to prevent
Something and there's a bunch of lollies involved. What is this shitty? Donnie Darko?
FBI registry edition. Look I'm all for setting up a time travel mystery, but it's painfully obvious
Oh, this is just a mediocre adaptation to a visual novel
Look, even this police officer could give less shits about the protagonists plot points. So what are you in for today?
Uh, I woke up with a girl on my crotch. Mm-hmm. Oh, and I'm from the future anything else
Nautical
Okay, well you seem like a mentally stable man who could be no threat to society here's your stuff you're free to go
This is it. It's our time boys. It's actual Yuri on land
So this seems like some cute girls doing ballet or performing arts school with some Yuri bait. I don't know
It looks nice, but it seems pretty standard. Wait. Wait, what wait, that's they're fighting now
What what why they fight this just part of the stage show
wait what what is going on
(in the background) oh my god she pushed her off
She's free falling to her death is that a talking giraffe, why is there a talking giraffe? Girl I think you're tripping balls
Shut up random talking giraffe! your tripping balls
Now she's joining in oh, oh, whoa
I have no idea what I watched, but it was awesome. I think
Man, this guy really loves falling from high places
Didn't you one of the high selling points of anime and not to be too simplistic?
Is that the the Japanese creators treat their audiences as though they have brains?
I want you to make a disgusted face and show me your underwear
Most parents always talk about how proud they are of their children, but in some instances that's not the case
Hi mom
I
Think I found a religion I can finally get behind. Sometimes I ask myself
Is there a line that needs to be drawn between the excitement of discovering a very specific new kink people will find you weird for?
and
Exceeding no limits of disappointment if your parents found out what you are really like
I'm I'm sorry. Mom. I made up my mind a long time ago. Oh, yeah
She's still falling. There are two types of sports anime
firstly theres
SPOORTS!!!
Bro you watching some SPORTS!!
their sports
Yeah, we watch anime for the sports
So let me break that down for you on one hand
You have a badminton anime with some of the most intense and well directed sports
choreography right off the bat if this opening match doesn't draw you in then
The amount of sweat coming off. These girls will fuck me. That's a lot of sweat man
We're just which is on a fucking roll today, aren't we my only issue so far is that it seems a bit dramatic
Look, I love drama in sports anime
But geez at least Lube me up before forcing it all in it's all a bit heavy-handed at the moment
I mean check out this unedited scene where one of the girls sees the culprits who murdered her entire family years ago
Damn. so dramatic
Oh
No way, sorry, I I got confused
That was just when she saw someone who beat her a badminton one time and on the other side, we have dead or alive extreme beachvollyball
Anime edition. I don't really have anything else to say. It's summer people. Just embrace it
You know, I never understood this show don't tell philosophy with film media like if we're adapting novels
why would you want to watch the anime adapt the novel when you could just sit there and
Read it like the heelflip actually intended now, some of you may look at this show about a gamer transported to a fantasy world
That's based on this game where he far-out levels everyone and as girls tripping over his feets and it's it's a fantasy world
but it does have some original ideas in it like
Well, this one has a girl named RAM, nope better I forgot about Reiser
You know, it doesn't really matter if it's similar because at least every ISA guy has their own unique spells and everything
Okay, many of you may be thinking how can you even be original in the Issei
ki,genre, anymore when every idea has been done
But the master of Ragnarok and lesser of I in Josh shows us that you can incorporate
Wacky ideas that we just haven't seen before in the genre because yeah, it's a nice acai. Yeah. It's another power fantasy
Yeah, he has a harem posse surrounding him but get this
This time the protagonist
has a
smartphone
Smart yeah, yeah
Yeah, something something's sexy men something something three seasons a movie and still no nipples something something keep it in your pants girls
But it should be illegal for water to look this good. I mean, this is just setting unrealistic expectations for every body of water
I now see in the future why can't you look as beautiful
Girl you're in the wrong show, but free eight the only show about diving this season as we also have Grand blue
Which is definitely a show about diving and not people getting shit-faced drunk, but no judgments here
I mean, this is genuinely funny and I think it was about time Japan embrace the frat boy college party comedy genre
But damn there is a lot of naked men here. I know we have to impress the girls
But when are we gonna get some good old fashioned fanservice?
Son of a bitch
Well, we've done it guys we finally made a waifu out of our blood congratulations
I mean over the Sun we were searching for best girl when she was in us all along we bleed best girl
We donates best girl best girl
Best girl gives us aids hey I just wanted to say that you are you you look really cute today
aww thanks for the compliment
What I wasn't talking to you I was talking to your tampon
Look, I know this has meant to be a fun edutainment sure about the inner workings of our body
But I just I just can't with a show I come out with more questions than I start with and I need answers
How can red blood cells blush? Yeah platelets are cute and all but there's a reason in society
We don't trust important construction work too fucking toddlers
Mitochondria do is that like important for the cell or something when we get to the sperm episode are they just gonna be playing fortnite?
How can blood bleed you you make up the blood? How each such what is happening, but you know what?
This means right are we finally gonna get the one and only waifu this community truly deserves
Cancer chan. Hey, look, it's attack on titan. Season 3. yaaay
Aren't we all excited. I mean its attack on Titan. We're still hyped right people were still hyped over this
I mean, it's it's attack on titan. Okay , let's say let's just play the opening you'll get you're gonna get hyped over the opening
Alright, let's just yeah. Yeah, this is this is this is getting you high try this this is working
Margarita's your hyped right?
Bakugo's mom
Look it's simple really most people don't understand that if you're being chased by an edgy serial killer in order to conquer edge you must
first become edge and
I think this first episode
title really captures the spirit of that now this is exactly what I needed after to clean my palates just a nice bubbly slice of
Life of a cute girl taking care of a loli and you know, it's refreshing to see your main character like this
I mean she's young but she's trying really hard to be
Responsible and I like her design as well because I think she's cute with her pink hair and oh god
She's fucking insane isn't she
Pink haired one
Why's it always the fucking pink haired one? Oh, hey. Look, it's Diet. Nichijou. Oh, hey look its diet. Yu-gi-oh hair
oh, hey look its diet every Idol show that's ever existed and
Now, I wish I was back at Angels of Death again CGI mecha
furries
The three genders look it's simple really most people don't understand that when Humanity is under attack and all. Hope is lost
In order to conquer a bad CGT. You must first become bad see, all right
I'm not even gonna pretend I knew what was going on, but I think that was the point of it
I've heard very good things about this writer
So I will stay on but at least it was nice enough to let us know it was a wild ride from the get-go
Instead of just slapping in our face right at the end
we have a fucking doorbell, you know, I don't know why I was expecting for a show with the title bananafish swim free little fishy
But I sure as hell wasn't expecting a stylish old-school gangster thriller set in New York. I was immediately gripped
Thanks to his visual designs grounded action direction
It feels less like an anime and more like an 80s action
Thriller probably because that was when the source material was made it was certainly more homoerotic than I expected
I mean the protagonist is so sexy
Everyone seems to be out for his dick even the villains are like god, I hate that hero. Yeah, me too
I bet his dick is too big
what was that? I bet he's like really good at sex. If I were to give a blind recommendation based on the first few episodes
This would be it. I mean it's got action
A cast that doesn't seem like your cookie cutter anime tropes and even some yaoi for you fujo's out there. Yep
I don't know about you, but I think this summer season has finally
landed
I believe i can fly
Hey guys, hope you enjoyed that video. Thank you again to knights Chronicle for sponsoring
This season's summer rundown if any of what I showed you in the beginning of this video
Interested you then all the links are in the description below and you can download it on whatever
Mobile device you have available for those you who also miss my Murray's Janvrin video
I release a motherfucking tea mug Limited Edition for those of you who still remember my first dead meme
so if you do want one of these limited edition mugs get them while you can because you only have a week left if you
Want to see my other seasonal stuff then click on this video here and you know
Like subscribe all that fucking usual shit if you want to but anyways, that's it for me
I've been Gigguk and I will see you all next time